the twenty joe saburi
next section kaisuzuki
i'd like to just explain that um the
first three skis
are all spelt the same we we can say
chokuzuki or kaishisuki
but the spelling's the same
if we say zuki kashizuki
chokuzuki kaishizuki
then the third one sounds like ski
but it's zuki it sounds like zuki
and this was because the japanese
language the tongue doesn't twist too
much
so they've even thought about the detail
of their speech
and that's how much perfectionist is
going into
the japanese language so
we may say in the western world
chokutzuki
kaishisuki shiroski
and we're not realizing how much our
tongue is turning and twisting
to make these sounds
it's ushered makes the
ski come out because it flows we don't
they don't have to twist their tongue a
piece of worthless information
but i just want you to know how much
detail we need to look at
within our aikido also
you know just oh it'll do
it i'm afraid it won't do because if
you're looking for perfection
and you're looking to find those senses
aikido then you have to look very deep
into the art
okay ocean city was very very small
you know extremely small the taller we
are
the more sway we're going to get the
more things we're going to get
and you'll often see teachers
swaying and leaning there's nothing
wrong with that because they're
actually going with the movement
now this is a very complex
kaishizuki is a very complex
ski and because
it's a spiraling is a spiraling twist
a spiraling twist it's not a pullback
and a ski it's as if
it's coming from this foot as if it's a
snake's tongue
coming out this way this way
so this end must not
the same as the first one don't come
round
reach it and turn the hand
i'll come back to so you can see
don't lift this up this is a fault if
you see people lifting their elbow it's
a fault
that means they're going to do that
if you do that look where the joe's
going it's going completely out of the
way and that's got to come all the way
back on target
if anything i'm going to get out of the
way so when i do this i stand the same
as before
first two fingers holding firm
not ever so tight but firm
i take this without my shoulder moving
in
and it comes up like this
like this
and then this little spiral and it's
transmitted
down the jar
done quickly
so we're having to avoid this
big circle
and then a ski
it comes from this
this point
and it's a twist it's a twist
it's a spiral a spiral
a spiral
some people different teachers do
different things
and the more i find the longer i'm doing
it
i do different things with my body so
you may disagree with this
but you have to find your own footwork
really
sometimes it's wide
[Applause]
sometimes it's wide same thing with the
wrist
as before passes the body not
inside the body outside the body
this hand again mustn't be too much over
it mustn't be up here like this this is
a fault
it must be down keep it down since you
used to say if your elbows up someone
can get you because it's i could have
multiple attack
it's not one-on-one even the weapons are
teaching you movement they're not
but they're to help your targets so
they're not like a separate thing
even though we look at them a separate
thing they're not a separate thing
they're helping develop your body
movement and to safeguard yourself
so since he would say if if you're up
high they can get an eq
on you or an immobilization so keep it
down where they can't
push it up
okay keep it down inside the body is
wrong
outside the body
look the joe slides so you're not
restricted if you hold too tight this
end this hand it will stop the hand
passing
let it slide through you're gripping
with these two
[Music]
again wide stance
or together stance
the body the more you do it the body
blends and flows with the weapons
we start the weapons off
then we become we become
we become attached to the weapon we we
become the shape of perhaps where the
weapon is going
okay so this is kaisuki
kai shizuki
[Music]
make sure you look ahead so many people
do this they live in their own head in
their work
in their own world and they're
daydreaming they're not looking at what
they're supposed to the target
they do this
watch down here there's nobody down here
the attackers at the end here
so look where you're thrusting she is
yep
it's pretty much a sideways body angle
chocolate
hi suzuki
kai suzuki
please study those and i hope they're
helping you you